[Risas]
guau
como impactado desde aquí menudo
escenario de hecho cuando venía para acá
venía pensando y si me equivoco y si me
quedo en blanco hasta me imaginado que
tropezaba con la moqueta roja os
imagináis que me caigo que miedo no
el caso es que el miedo es un mecanismo
de defensa nos ayuda es una herramienta
súper útil es un cimiento de nuestra
psique yo lo comparo con el sentido
arácnido de spiderman ese superpoder que
tiene para saber cuando hay un peligro
cerca el miedo funciona igual en
nosotros nos ayuda a estar alerta para
mantenernos vivos
con este razonamiento uno podría pensar
que entonces porque puedo tener miedo
hasta encima del escenario en este
momento
hay algún peligro que yo no conozco que
quizás hay una trampilla con cocodrilos
aquí debajo de la moqueta he tenido
algunos con un arma
bueno si en algún momento me veis un
punto de la cee en alguna parte del
cuerpo por favor avisarme tengo que
salir corriendo
el caso es que podemos tener miedo a un
examen a un insecto inofensivo
pero también podemos tener muchísimo
miedo lo que los profesionales llamamos
fobias una fobia ya es incapacitante nos
dan ataques de ansiedad
tenemos taquicardias sudores fríos nos
falta el aire hay una imperiosa
necesidad de salir huyendo
de hecho huir es la respuesta más
natural al miedo pero también tenemos lo
que llamamos respuesta evitativa o
conducta evitativa qué quiere decir esto
que no solo yo tengo un miedo y salgo
corriendo sino que ya evitó lo que creo
que va a poder generar ese miedo
imaginar lo que nos puede condicionar
nuestro día a día pero qué pasa si yo no
puedo evitar
ese miedo que tengo un examen o si me
hace muy bien en el trabajo
vamos a ir comunidad normal
lo más paradójico de todo es que la
forma más eficiente más efectiva de
gestionar un miedo es que nos
enfrentemos a él
que faenan
yo es confieso que yo tengo pánico a las
alturas quiero explicar una historia que
me pasó a mí yo tengo en casa una
consola que permite jugar la realidad
virtual
y me compré un juego el de spiderman
entonces imaginarme a mí en casa de pie
con las gafas y empezando a jugar por
primera vez al principio estás con tu
avatar y empiezas a practicar tus
diferentes tipos de armas que en este
caso son tipos de telarañas y cuando ya
estás listo te subes a una grúa
yo ahí ya empecé a sudar
mi primera reacción fue andar un poquito
hacia atrás hasta que toque el sofá con
las piernas y me dije a mí misma estás
en el salón de tu casa estás en estado
de tu casa y de pronto la grúa se rompe
imaginaros se supone que tenía que haber
cogido la grúa con las telarañas no fui
capaz
con mi respuesta with me tuve que quitar
las gafas
sin saberlo me iba a exponer a mi miedo
y es así como funciona la realidad
virtual en psicología nos exponemos a
nuestros miedos pero de una forma segura
les explico muy brevemente cómo funciona
nos ponemos unas gafas y veremos un
entorno en 3-d creado por ordenador lo
chulo de esto es que podemos interactuar
con este entorno
podemos mirar en todas direcciones
podemos hablar y contactar con los
avatares podemos movernos en el espacio
y poniendo el ejemplo del escenario el
profesional que nos acompaña en todo el
proceso puede modificar el entorno en el
que vamos a estar
puede haber público puede que no haya
público nos pueden hacer preguntas nos
pueden increpar puede haber
distracciones una risita un bostezo
forma parte como un videojuego vamos
superando cada vez dificultades de tal
forma que cuando nos enfrentemos en la
vida real los genes los gestionamos con
éxito porque va a estar ahí el
profesional con nosotros además
llevaremos un sensor biométrico en los
dedos que automáticamente en un
ordenador refleja nuestro estado
emocional y físico a través de ver el
pulso y la sudoración el profesional
allí nos ayudará y nos enseñará
herramientas para gestionar la situación
qué chulo no
la pregunta aquí está si yo sé que es un
entorno en 3-d
como puede ser que yo tenga las mismas
reacciones emocionales y físicas pues
eso se explica con dos mecanismos muy
simples el primero
es la inmersión qué significa esto que
vuestra mente se va a olvidar de dónde
está nos ha pasado alguna vez que
leyendo un libro pasa una ambulancia
tiene ni la oí siquiera o incluso viendo
una película de miedo que sintamos ese
miedo y estamos en la butaca del cine
con el sofá de casa eso es lo que hace
nuestra mente como decimos
coloquialmente nos hemos metido en la
película o en el libro no es automático
tarda un ratito pero una vez lo hace
estamos inmersos en lo que estamos
haciendo
el segundo mecanismo no hay que permitir
que lo enseñe con un ejemplo
y quiero que miren la imagen no hace
falta que yo os diga qué figura
geométrica hay aquí porque vuestra mente
lo que está haciendo es tapar los huecos
rellenarlos y darle sentido a la imagen
aunque el triángulo no esté dibujado no
es necesario
tengo en cuenta que vuestra mente es muy
plástica y junto con estos dos
mecanismos
el cerebro la mente es capaz de poder
trabajar en un entorno habitual virtual
como si fuera real
os conquisté una cosa la radio virtual
no solo funciona con las fobias también
funcionan otras patologías como la
depresión la ansiedad generalizada las
adicciones trastornos
obsesivo-compulsivos trastornos
alimentarios
la realidad virtual es muy útil en la
salud mental y nos puede ayudar y mucho
podemos practicar nuestros superpoderes
y aprender herramientas y armas nuevas
para con salvamos fuera lo que tenemos
con éxito
una es ficción es ciencia
uy las gafas puestas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]